[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is it okay with beautiful like the
fourth of July the riders get changed
yeah but I keep going
nothing's going great baby getting all
the breaks
fifty-five hundred head on I hold you
till the big day yes
Sam I'll need some new clothes
you'll have plenty when you collect our
jackpot I'll need him right away Sam
what it has to wear black
we made it look a minute before you bust
something you come to join me take a
plane huh fast with that much money I'll
travel by armored car don't forget to
tell me how things are going here
write to me general delivery Washington
DC Sam just mean it's okay for now I'm
gonna take a better when we get back
together again
baby I'm gonna hate being away from your
salon don't think I'm gonna win joy
sting you meet up for a few weeks for
both of us but it's worth it but what we
got coming up huh
all gonna be different with us
everything we want new here's the Mexico
City we'll be beginning a new life
good bye baby they tell you I'm gone
forever don't you believe it
and remember no tears family popcorn at
the puke don't you worry about that
business tonight tell us something like
that I must be daddy about you so what I
am this will work out and now had an all
time deal
well what I huh Sam never doubt me
if we get the right thing every day
get the other side I'll Drive
and husband here's get off all right
camel soon be far away it's a happy
thought forgive me for getting me down
here at this awful hour I couldn't wait
to be with you hungry no I just want to
relax and enjoy myself
let's get gone
I don't understand why yes to get more
grateful after all I did it I keep
telling you everything's gonna be
perfect but you don't tell me why don't
you trust me
I'm not Sam no you're not I need to
thank you
don't start counting man till you're
ready to let me know what the deal is
all right AM double-crossed me right
from the start spending all that money
on me and making me think he was loaded
wasn't my god make sure liked me so I
married found out that he'd spent all
his money putting on a show to land me
to bet he was crying and I was stuck
with him doing my own house were cooking
for him tell me I think I haven't heard
from you before finally I got fed up and
told him I was gonna leave him my
brother's not getting bleep desperate so
after a couple of days he came up with
an idea Mike meant like things dodgy
a couple of hours ago down at the Sunset
Beach hotel a room registered to a mr.
Sam Grover caught on fire and a body
would hurtling all in flames out the
window after that all they could have
possibly found was a body so badly
burned and smashed it they'd never be
able to tell what was accepted I've had
on Sam's watching me do you realize what
you're in on Edna who's Bonnie wasn't
just a court today I'm got from an ID to
take her in psalmody those used car
dealers even taking stiffs as trade-ins
nap they haven't been holed up in that
hotel room for three days I don't think
I like any of this you told me Sam was
away on business
he was sweet with a fifty thousand
dollar project
$2,000 imply the charts tonight Sam
Olivia to exist that's why you went away
to disappear it's gonna be waiting for
you somebody's join him with that 50
grand and live happily ever and only
you're not going away but I am I'm going
anyplace you want to go I'll be right
there
mrs. Sam Grover yes yeah I've been here
no no he isn't gonna have to talk to you
mrs. Grove oh please come in when do you
expect your husband well I don't exactly
know he hasn't been home in several days
why is he in some sort of trouble I
don't know I'm afraid I'll have to ask
you to come down to headquarters with me
why what's the matter I'm not at liberty
to say oh wait why they get dressed
okay check on it sit down mrs. Grover I
understand you haven't seen your husband
since Monday that's right I haven't
what's this all about has Sam done
something any idea where we could find
him
he just left without saying where he was
going
you and he had some trouble a little
argument
nothing serious was it serious enough
that he might have moved into a hotel
I guess so he left home mad and I
haven't heard from him since
please whatever's happened tell me
ever see these before you don't even
look like my husband the watch I gave in
my first Christmas together where'd you
find these
a room registered to Sam Grover at the
Sunset Beach Hotel caught on fire these
were on the body to plunge through the
window into the alley we can go on with
a questioning later you'd like to lie
down for a while mrs. Grover that's why
you brought me here to homicide please I
want to know now how it happened and you
think of any reason anybody would want
to kill him mrs. Grover
no no Sam didn't have any enemies of any
kind are you sure there's nothing that
you can tell us that was never mixed up
in any trouble of any kind I can't
understand I just can't believe they
couldn't get any clear prints look you
must have some reason to think that this
was done deliberately now if somebody's
responsible I want them caught mrs.
Grover we haven't any evidence there's
nothing for us to work with if you can't
give us some leads all I can figure is
an accident case that's all I can say to
the coroner's inquest accidental death
[Music]
but a lovely creature is that your
daughter
my granddaughter she's studying surgery
and what's lip naturally for a while I
had me really desperate murder that'd
mess up the whole thing it came out all
right I think I gave quite a performance
we should gotta cut me at the morgue I
was really terrific kind of a cold house
the plaintiff don't have much money you
could put on quite an act
it was awful having to look at some poor
burn broken body and say yes it's Sam I
know what Sam I'm still shaking now I've
got to see you and of course we realize
your great loss mrs. Grover believe me
you have the deepest and sincerest
sympathy of ourselves personally of the
company but in your bereavement it may
fortify you somewhat to know that there
are no financial worries to add to your
grief that's why I've come at this time
him was very good at you your husband
left you quite well provided for with
his insurance if you'll just sign these
applications please mrs. Grover I didn't
realize there was any insurance that
came to me I have a good policy for Sam
he originally took it out with his son
Thomas beneficiary then sometime after
he married you he changed it in your
favor Sam often spoke of doing that I
told him that any money I received from
his death wouldn't give me anything
possible happiness the company isn't
completely satisfied with the police
report the police said Sam evidently did
what people most often do in the panic
of finding themselves trapped and
burning he he jumped out the window
certainly appears to have all the
elements of pure accident we don't know
we don't have to find out but if the
police accepted it as an accident we
aren't always satisfied with the theory
the police except it's more or less of a
formality investigating any case where
this possible doubt taggin I think to
think that there is an impossible doubt
been so difficult for me to resign
myself even to perfective Sam being dead
by this horrible accident but in any
case mrs. Grover you'll receive the
money but before we settle I don't have
to do a certain amount of
- Katie I understand of course my report
ought to be ready within a week unless
there are disturbing difficulties you'll
hear from me by
I think you'll like it here rooms ready
min speaks you want to show the
gentleman there's nothing grand mr.
Johnson but it's it's comfortable and
quiet
that's about all I ask I my other two
rumors are away at work all day there's
no one around except Hilda she won't
bother you that's fine
frankly the real reason I'm in
Washington is confidential
you know we certainly do know the rest
of us here have government jobs we never
asked questions of each other everybody
Minds his own business yeah I guess I
came to the right place well coming on
oh come here
Thanks I hoped you'd come when you're
paired I'm glad you're here are you it
isn't the same without him is it you
haven't been around for a long time
sorry it had to be these circumstances
it brought you back I want you to know
that I don't hold anything against you
for coming between dad and me the way
you did
I hope not there's no reason to it it
was all a misunderstanding if having you
gave my father a couple of years of
happiness that's fine with me I tried to
make him happy Tom I'd like to feel that
I did and believe me I don't hold any
resentment about dad changing the
insurance policy so you get the money oh
I never wanted him to I didn't know
anything about it until yesterday you
wanted to leave you well fixed and he
did you'll be all right I'm going to
give you your share Tom I'm sure Sam
would expect that thanks Edna I don't
want any of the money I'll get along
okay on my own I want to be sure did you
all get married yet I was going to but
well this postpones that for a while
anyway I think your father would want
you to go along the way you planned just
as though nothing had happened I can't
know this hanging over me well it's not
a family scandal Tom your father died in
a fire yeah I'm not so sure it was an
accident well how can you say that Tom I
know this hit you very hard it it does
me too
but we must keep our senses the police
and the insurance company have
investigated and they've accepted it as
accidental death
I'm not making any accusations against
anybody but I'm gonna find out if there
was anything criminal about my father's
death and if there was I'll make sure
that something is done about it
I don't know what I figured I could find
out mr. wild idea that I could tell
something by the way she's taking she's
smart she'd been putting on a big crying
act I'd have been sure she was thinking
to cover up something are you going back
to the police doesn't seem any use and
talking to them the insurance people
anymore we could test my suspicions what
about a private detective there's one
who doesn't work for my boss sometimes
he he seems to be pretty good
he probably cost too much he's sort of
eccentric he may take the case chief if
it interests him isn't exactly what
we've been saving our money for I want
to do all I can
I know your father meant a great deal to
you I can't just stand still and take it
the way he died maybe we will talk to
that investigator friend of yours
[Music]
yes mr. Stewart are you busy I'm no
certainly going to me this is delightful
you're here at last my dear you're being
followed
did you know but the Stewart this is my
fiancee your fiancee how do you do how
do you do you depress me deeply Marylin
however I shall subject the young man to
a thorough investigation and advise you
whether to proceed with matrimony Tom
need your help mr. Stewart really I
think I'm qualified to help you out of
any trouble
look do come over and sit down
I am now ready to be helpful I guess
first of all I better tell you that I
can only afford about $50 I'm very glad
you did tell me that first a sudden
lethargy is descended upon me
you may now tell me young man what
troubles you $50 worth go ahead please
Tom okay mr. Stuart the other night my
father Sam Grover family Grover I find I
must apologize for my earlier levity and
you are here obviously because there's
some question in your mind concerning
the circumstances of your father's exit
from this Pleasant little world
only it isn't so pleasant to me right
now and I don't think it was any
accident which is a direct divergence
from the theory accepted by our esteemed
police department I join you in doubting
their infallibility I have a hunch my
father was murdered I imagine we finally
got around to fire this young lady
brought you here the motive might be of
some use frankly I haven't much to go on
mr. Stewart just my suspicions my
father's wife
his second wife she's not my mother yes
I I've seen her pictures in the Daily
Gazette dad's life insurance pays her
$50,000 mm-hmm $50,000 nice round sum I
think we may well consider mrs. Grover
our number-one suspect and you have
indeed a motive laddie
I am achieved about the possibilities I
shall give the matter definite
consideration I guess you'd want the $50
now not a franc till I come up something
tangible I shall get in touch with you
when I have something stimulating to
report you're being awfully kind mr.
Stewart yes I suppose I am
goodbye that's right
[Music]
[Music]
what kind of a post office is this right
here in the home headquarters of the US
Postal Service a man comes around
faithfully every day and you don't turn
up a postcard or anything for not even a
bill nothing for Sam Johnson nothing
thanks
hello yes Sam
where are you I'll call you back
[Music]
[Music]
allow me who are you coming to Stuart
one of the better private investigators
how'd you get in here
the doors are most tomes are very
vulnerable to pass keys I thought that
our little telephone conversation
entitled me to guest privileges I don't
recall any telephone conversation with
you
it was rather brief I didn't allow you
to be very communicative I'm awfully
afraid I hung up rather rudely right
after you said Sam where are you
I was so startled voice from the dead I
I didn't know what I was saying you said
just that I think your answer is very
gratifying you don't look like the type
to play telephone tricks on widows for
your amusement I suppose it does need a
little explanation yes it does I was
engaged by young mr. Tom Grover to
investigate his father's untimely demise
I shouldn't think an upset son's wild
ravings would inspire anyone with your
experience well frankly the boys problem
doesn't it just me particularly really
what would money trade you'll come to
the wrong place let's not forget mrs.
Grover I am aware your husband is alive
you have a problem you I have meet I
misjudged you my dear in the case of
this sort ones first suspicions I'll
have to be rather nasty you know I found
that out people seem to get the idea I
killed fam so I could collect his
insurance I fell into that error except
that I didn't feel you could have
accomplished it alone I wouldn't even
have thought of it in pursuing my false
premise I regretfully announced that I
stoop to employing the basis procedure
of my profession and that must be pretty
bait it's almost always a double
business in your case was no exception I
was quite bored following you and that
young man any particular young man that
some chap I I believe his name is Rick
so you've seen ray and me together
that's not enough my dear it's quite
sufficient to have made it seem likely
you and your young man contrived Sam's
death making it look like an accident
so that after you'd collected the
insurance you and the boyfriend could go
away together
you'll never find anything to implicate
ray possibly not getting any material
evidence against you two would have
required some physical effort on my part
and I'm a lazy creature
besides character traits us so much more
intriguing
I'm sure people's minds are more
interesting than their fingerprints
absolutely I find we have one thing in
common
you and I you and I it takes money to
make us happy money isn't everything
they say speaking of money I possess
certain priceless jewels of information
right there any father close association
with this rape fellow would elevate
eyebrows among the insurance and police
people if you really have an evil mind a
very valuable asset in my profession
dealing with the people that I - no
doubt and the revelation that your
husband is actually alive and you knew
it when you sign the insurance claim
would inevitably result in your
conviction for fraud I have a feeling
you're not going to tell them no neither
of my client nor I have anything to gain
by your being sent to prison I'm not
hollering help yet you're in no position
to help personally I hope very much did
you get the money the full amount that's
what I've been waiting for and I feel
definitely that the son tom should share
in the benefits from the insurance I
wondered how you were gonna put the
proposition
didn't Tom tell you that I offered in
some of the money and he refused to take
any part of it yes but then you could
say how much now I am in the position to
name the amount how nice for you I feel
that five thousand would be a fitting
some the lad wants to get married I
suppose you realize I won't get any five
thousand until the insurance company
pays off up until that point my client
and I shall be Pentagon's of patients
you will keep in touch with me I'm sure
mm-hmm constantly
[Music]
no jack mainly because you young Tom
managed to complicate matters so there's
been some delay but relax everything's
okay now the money ought to come through
within another week or so and then you
can expect me ferry
I'm sending you a nice gift package of
California fruit which you must miss
terribly back there you see I'm thinking
about you know take it easy oh boy I I
know you must be nervous so am I only
there's nothing to worry about but
please don't get upset into anything
crazy
please just stay planted there lay low a
little Locker and as soon as I get the
money I'll be on my way to you
[Music]
oh good morning mr. Johnson
morning the other I guess you'll even
bother to take a hat off I don't
understand
landlady asked me to tell you she
wouldn't need she any longer sorry hi I
wonder this is peak never complained to
my work I guess it's because she's gonna
quit her own job and take care of the
house herself oh well it doesn't matter
I'll get another position a better one
this peak old me for a week and a half
did she leave my pay oh your pain uh-huh
that was lame what's funny - she knows
she owes me everybody else gone for the
day
no one will be here till evening no you
see you hanging around I'll remind mrs.
P you can pick up your money tomorrow
morning
you've got a lot of nice solid
substantial stuff here yeah my wife take
it all out she didn't want to be around
this morning leave this business of an
embarrassing put alone a $500 make you
happy 500 I was thinking about a lot
more money in that living room dining
room kitchen four bedrooms upstairs
that's a lot of furniture
well we allow about ten percent on our
assessment I'll be glad to recommend a
loan on that basis of the company okay
it's only for an emergency anyway if
you'll be Natalie office this afternoon
without the cash boy oh thanks a lot
oh you'll notify us if you intend to
move this tab oh don't worry about the
stuff we'll be here
it isn't going noplace okay
give me the number of the American
Airlines this is what you wanted isn't
it tell no thanks I know if there's
anything more of his you want you'll let
me know won't you yeah well the
insurance money should come through in a
day or so and then everything will be
all right won't it nothing will ever be
all right until I find out what really
happened two dead what is it just how
much money do you think you can get out
of me anyway I told you I don't want any
money from you oh don't play so innocent
sure that's what you told me very
upstanding and honorable and then you
said that Huntington steward around a
gouge made good I don't know what you're
talking course not you wouldn't I talked
to Stuart about sting if he could find
out anything about my father's death
that's all Stuart told me today that he
hasn't anything on you or has he you
better go Tom you're being ridiculous
maybe I am but I don't think so
Tom the pipe don't forget the pipes
again Tom let's not fight anymore now
that your father's gone why can't we be
friends
you lie to me you told me you didn't
have anything on internet talk I can't
explain with your mottling my vocal
cords all right now what do you know
that's worth money there now I find it
impossible to express myself
intelligently under the constant right
of your violence I sit down okay I'm
waiting Stuart
you know raped Eldon no who is he
a handsome young friend vendor Grover's
I might say a very good friend now we're
getting somewhere
when I was able by my Machiavellian
machinations to learn of Eros
association gone it seemed quite
possible that and then he had conspired
to do away with your problems so they
could have each other and plenty of
money besides that's it we've got it
that was my conclusion the may I rise
now I should like to repair by
appearance
that have put this way before you have
it in - why don't you tell me about this
guy right before why don't you tell the
police I didn't tell the police because
the deeds seem to event company so
adroitly there was no evidence all we
could possibly prove his motive I had
what I believed was a better plan
yeah sure use what you knew to put the
bite on enter and make yourself some
money out of my father's death My dear
boy my plan is for you to receive the
benefit from the insurance you think I
want any part of the proceeds from my
father being murdered I quite see your
point a very admirable attitude I don't
like you cutting yourself in either they
often cut my own ideas about what to do
with her friend that guy I suppose is
useless to advise you against any
aggressive action in my book they kill
my father I had an intuition you'd lose
your head when you learned about Edna
and her boyfriend why don't you let me
have a chat with this ray cuz I'm gonna
have a long talk with him myself as an
older and wiser head I must warn you
that pursuing this any further we'll
only be disastrous to you maybe I'm
thinking mostly about how disastrous
it's gonna be the head met their friend
ray
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll leave this open Toby
there's nothing to be scared of
moving together for three long weeks
[Music]
look around oh we still have to play it
safe and it's not allowed anything spoil
at all now don't have the rest of our
lives together
I wish we were gonna be married right
away I hate leaving alone tomorrow what
was your idea we take off separately and
meet later it's really smarter that way
Edna right now I wish I had even thought
of it maybe it isn't so smart maybe you
won't come to join me I'll be following
right behind me
fresco then Diamondhead and the boat the
dykes one week after yours
[Music]
Edna I need some no clothes and have to
get by until I meet you over there
whose ring write to a chick
[Music]
hey taking my from him
get used to it Lam and offers you quite
a future I'll put on it for dancing hey
ray honey you sure you won't go with me
in the morning we could change your
ticket
that's much better if you slip away
quietly and leave me here then nobody
will suspect us well you'll notice when
I drop out of sight see you soon
sweetheart
[Music]
[Music]
what do you want
[Music]
with it
see ya what's the matter well I didn't
recognize you with that moustache Oh Sam
you should have let me know I was
leaving in the morning yeah where are
you going to Washington of course them
to meet you I got the money this is a
great way for me to have to find out
I wrote you yesterday there's an a me a
letter on the way to Washington you must
have had it where's the dough in the
bank Sam all safe how much of it nearly
all I had to get a few things naturally
tickets and sure take you you got the
letter didn't you explaining what took
so long
Tom complicating things and that's all I
got in the basket of fruit well Tom kept
messing around trying to prove it wasn't
an accident
you thought you were murdered nice no
the kid still cares what happened to his
old man nice to know somebody does
I guess I've given the kid a pretty
rotten deal he's a good boy before you
expect when I came in what did you think
of what my girlfriend I had to have some
company when you were away husband's
working up in Alaska I saw you come home
with a guy Oh with Ray Oh that Karen's
boyfriend you were in the McCarron we
were playing cards together when you get
back this afternoon
Sam what's that for just to make sure I
get my share of the dough what's a
little unnecessary till I get my twenty
five thousand you are not gonna have one
minute alone I'm tired of being alone
listen Sam why split the money we can
still go to Mexico can't we be wonderful
where novelist I read about a little
character place called Tesco with what
we've got we could live in luxury they
no worries too bothers it would be
heavenly to him there isn't gonna be any
Mexico all I want is my cut of the money
and I'm getting away from here and you
turn off the lights
I'll be away tonight at that a good
sleep Sam yeah can I do whatever I want
with my share of the money
sure well you're having about half as
much as expected it's gonna be quite a
blow to Karen's boyfriend he may not
like that but my dear boy
I wouldn't want to ruin that pretty
scarf I offended myself down to the
night in a new robe in pyjamas purchased
today particularly for a quiet evening
at home therefore I have no intention of
forsaking my ivory tower or love all
money that is your haven't enough money
but do I have to go to work on you again
tom it is very unfair of you to
constantly threaten to put this on a
physical basis but keep it on a mental
level I've got some surprises for you
very well what brings you charging into
my sanctuary like a young bullet this
he's an hour a little while ago somebody
shot ray Belding three times he ought to
be dead it certainly should be does
credit for the achievement go to you I
wouldn't come tell you where sins have
been confessed to me was it Edna that
beat you to him a man a friend of Edna's
any one of our acquaintances I couldn't
recognize him from where I was hiding
mm-hmm a mysterious man planning to
badness comes out of the night and kills
her sweetheart hmm
I find that intriguing oh and I'm
beginning to think that Ray wasn't her
sweetheart in spite of what you said you
know you could be wrong
anyway it looks like he wasn't number
one boy with her if you came crashing in
here with a few facts give them to me
don't stand there theorizing I was on my
way to rave beldon's to pay him a visit
and give him the works are you sure you
didn't this as I started to his door I
heard the shots I ducked back to the
shadows
I saw a man coming and you couldn't get
enough of a look to identifying but I
followed him you hurried right to Edna's
place he went in didn't come out
looks like he's head man well at least
you're beginning to be forgiven for
disturbing me must have something to do
with my father's death
I didn't told you what otherwise
concerned about babe
pinked what happened tonight makes me
think that Rey must not have been her
accomplice really who do you think was
the man I saw tonight he and had no
murdered dad
Rey know too much about it so the man
had to put Rey out of the way you
realize of course that you are the most
appropriate suspect for the killing of
Felton
it's the reason I came to you instead of
going to the police you made quite a
fuss claiming that your father was
murdered now the widow's most likely
collaborator is killed it did not
certainly seem you did it for event I
know that I'm gonna spot very definite
it it extremely foolhardy at the moment
for you to go any further you've come to
the right place I hate to lay low now
that we're hot on the trail stay out of
sight until you get a message for me
this must be handled with the objective
which I am capable
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I wasn't asleep then why didn't you stop
what for you were a fool to let me take
this I'm gonna kill you
why get your freedom with nearly 25
grand you want all the money that's the
idea because I've gotta kill you before
you kill me because I hate you so much I
despise myself for ever having had
anything to do with you every time you
came dandy I hated it whenever you touch
me it made me ill did report to me
I hated the way you let me push you
around the stupid way is sacrificed for
me I think that would have been
beautiful and anyone else idle Oh did
you know I'm gonna fix it so I don't
ever have to see you think about you
again ya been foolish I meant they'll
hang your port because I shot some
stranger who broke into my home and
can't get away with it at the time
you'll recognise me not what I'm gonna
leave of you he won't
[Music]
doesn't have to be loaded
[Music]
the shame laughter that pretty speech
[Music]
no wrong yet no I wasn't gonna kill you
the money isn't why I came back all I
ever wanted was your witness you were
everything to me
money didn't mean a thing that's a way
to keep you're near me there's a time
when I thought I'd died you ever left me
but now I think I can get along alright
without you we were through with me I
don't want you anymore very nice time so
all I want now is what's coming to me
I share of the insurance and you're
going to the bank and get it in cash I'm
taking my forehead my five thousand you
see no reason why I should pay for any
tickets I'm a little yeah I guess that
polishes off everything between us was
it yeah yeah I'll be right there
well I need to remind you that neither
of us in any spot to turn the other end
of the police I just want to forget you
Sam well have a happy new year any place
so long
love maybe a little overrated
is this Kristen five 302 one is calling
is raving it yeah he's here who wants
him
for a woman she didn't talk very much I
hope there's enough of the boys to get a
tracer on that call got something
lieutenant check made out to Ray bellman
for 200 bucks signed by a woman
Edna Grover how he is lieutenant hit the
landlord you know the one that found him
no I was over here this morning
the neighbors vid complain about how
loud he played the radio late at night
and gives us a lot of such thing no I
warned him several times but last night
was the last straw about 12 o'clock they
say the radio was blasting the walls
down that must be about the time he got
it I came over this morning to evict mr.
bellman to tell him he had to move out
and I found it you rented the place to
anybody yet oh no you got yourself a new
tenant this is just what I've been
looking for lieutenant could I talk to
this gentleman for a few minutes go
ahead Wow yeah mm-hmm
got a trace on that call lieutenant the
pole is lifted out of the name of mrs.
Edna Grover well I'll let you boys
finish up here I'm gonna have a talk
with a blonde
Oh mrs. Gerber nice to see you yeah
quite a girl I wonder if it was worth it
to the guys who really knew you
what something seems to happen to your
men please what are you talking about
first it was your husband Sam now Belden
wait this was no accident three shots
pumped into him what are you saying what
happened to Ray he's dead
there's nothing definite that says you
did it but things tie you in so I'll
just have to take you downtown with me
[Music]
doesn't live there anymore huh that's
his father died I see did he leave a
forwarding of this there's an old friend
of Tom's a very anxious get in touch
with it's very important no how's that
possible for him to call me well thanks
anyway
well you got in there hey wait a minute
there's nobody in here bit mean Oh house
detective you look like a better class
of hotel I sincerely hope so
what is this what do you want turn
around please turn over toward the wall
stop
lean forward with your arms wide your
hands against the wall spread your feet
far apart looking for anything in
particular
cigarettes
you wouldn't be a policeman no gun
no only a few hundred dollars I'm deeply
disappointed my heart's breaking
you may now abandon that ridiculous
posture thanks
move over and stand looking out that
window
it might offer a splendid view nine
stories down maybe I don't like any of
this maybe I'll make you use that gun
that is precisely why I have it handy it
would give you a lot of explaining to do
to the police I think the police would
listen very attentively and I strongly
urge you do the same right now oh very
soon the discovery of the body of a man
murdered last night would interest the
police in any possible prospects well
they got to do with me I think the
police would be delighted to learn that
last night you were seen going into the
house of one ray Belden three shots
later you were the one who came up I
followed you here knowing pretty well
who might find because I asked myself
who would kill ray bells and then spend
the rest of the night in Edna coruthers
apartment and the answer came to me
immediately I thought why of course
Sam girl who would do the deed and think
no one would ever suspect him because
he's supposed to be dead did you kill
your wife too
I never heard of any of the people you
mentioned so I guess we've got nothing
in common to talk about anyway you can't
prove that I'm a Sam Grover have you
forgotten that your fingerprints are on
record yes they would make you Sam
Grover mr. gee they wouldn't make me the
murder of any ray Belden perhaps you
have that color but there certainly
would be considerable interest in you as
a man who swindled an insurance company
hey wait a minute I have tried to break
it to you gently but I hope I've made
you realize the situation if I turn you
over to the police you'll face charges
of both fraud and murder well what do
you want not all not everything you have
I wouldn't want to leave you with
nothing to lose you might be moved to do
something desperate how much say five
thousand dollars what am i buying with
that your absolute freedom mr. Govan
well I know you won't still turn me in
the after I pay off how does anyone ever
know in cases like this however you are
blessed taking less than the usual check
but break am I getting don't you see it
would be very damaging to my excellent
reputation as a detective to have to
report that I had my hands on a man
wanted for fraud and murder and let him
slip away you shall have your Liberty
mr. Grover and at a very moderate price
I maintain I haven't got the money here
I'm fairly certain of that I followed
you to the bank this morning but you got
in before I could park my car I presume
you put the money in the safety deposit
box naturally I didn't want all that
money with me over the weekend and the
place doesn't open till Monday morning I
should be patient in the meantime I have
the keys to the box is my security yeah
say am i buying any information with my
five grand and who claims they saw me
coming out of Rebellion's huh care for a
shop your son huh you'll be relieved to
learn that he didn't recognize you
does he does he know I'm still alive
Am I I thought it was kinder to leave
him in ignorance
perhaps this better be thinks his old
man is dead I feel a certain
responsibility to the lad
I've never liked him I don't think of
something to tell him and I shall cut
back to see how you are naturally you
could run out on me and leave town but
that way you'd be letting me collect all
the money I'll be here
remember you can't open that box without
my signature for that matter I don't
even know what name you used
we definitely need each other
united we stand divided we fall
why don't you want to tell us mrs.
Grover what was there between you and
Ray Belden why did you phone him this
morning to say goodbye I was going away
we know you had a ticket to Honolulu you
were all set for a fast getaway after
you killed him
I didn't kill him he had a ticket to
Honolulu too for a boat a week later he
didn't want to follow your thought he
shot him he was making you pay off for
something you wanted to get rid of it
that's only human the check was for what
it said for dancing lessons I think
you're on the wrong beat if she shot him
why would she phone his place to make
sure he was dead what about the guns
remember the bullets Andrade Bevans body
came from the gun we found in your
bedroom I told you I didn't know
anything about the gun well how do you
think it got in your bedroom
tell us somebody put it there last night
while I was out I went to the movies
somebody planted it to make it look like
you did the killing hi Oh Tom Grover my
husband's son mr. hutton knows tom
didn't think it father's death was an
accident
he thought I had something to do with
Sam's death tom threatened to kill me
maybe you did murder your husband and
rebelled and knew about it that was why
you put him out of the way I didn't kill
my husband and I didn't have any reason
to kill ray the last time I saw ray he
was alive you say you were home last
night at the time he was killed who can
prove that with somebody with you your
last night in town a girlfriend any
friend a relative
no-nobody I was wrong Ivan speaking
okay
the fingerprints on the gun there's
gotta be enough for now that's plenty oh
you can come in now
mrs. Grover your salvation
this is mr. Nicholas the bail bondsman
mrs. grobart how do you do
that's a wonderful question as soon as I
read of your predicament I came right
over
I'm sure you'd like to be out of this
oppressive atmosphere as quickly as
possible for what to go to race funeral
after that what's left for me
anyway that's absurd you can't give up
now just because Ray's gone you'll get
over the shock gonna tell yourself mrs.
Grover you and I are armed with certain
facts the police aren't aware unless
you've told them
so then what who killed vain Belden you
know you know I didn't do it yes my dear
why should you pay for someone else's
crying you do as I say and I think we'll
be able to get you released on bail I
presume that you're prepared to pay a
reasonable fee between the two of you
this is gonna cost me play but it'll be
worth it
thanks very much
no no I didn't want to talk to him I
just won over he still worked there
thanks very much goodbye you get me a
messenger please room nine eleven the
blonde would have appeared before Judge
Honnold dressed in a symphony of black
with matching accessories and she walked
out of the courtroom she smiled sweetly
for the reporters still proclaiming look
honey I'm in no mood to listen to
descriptions of Edna just give me a
quick briefing
Edna's going to plead guilty to shooting
rebuildin guilty when she didn't do it
the charges reduced to manslaughter
she's out on bail after all she's done
her story she shot ray Belden in
self-defense
don't you see Maryland L don't know that
she and the guy I saw murdered dead
that's why he had to be eliminated
Edna's covering for the real killer
because she'll have a better chance for
the jury are you going to phone Stewart
sure he's supposed to let me know how
he's doing trailing by mr. X the Tom
Grove at this address that's me
you sign this receipt please
Thanks take it ask from Stuart $5,000
nope it says just forget about your
father and be happy
hey messenger the way you work my brain
is always active Edna delighted to see
you my dear I haven't any time for
polite conversation I can't he for one
thing I want you to find Sam
just when we found a way to save you
from conviction for a crime you didn't
commit
don't for heaven's sakes go out to do
something to hang yourself he killed a
man I loved nothing you do now can bring
way back hey let's be practical Sam
being guilty of fraud and murder is
undoubtedly a desperate and dangerous
man to corner not my cup of tea all you
have to do is find out where he is I'll
take it from there
it's nearly $10,000 do it I'm not even
tempted the money you gave me has made
life so luxurious I have every intention
of keeping myself alive to enjoy it we
have a feeling you don't want me to find
this I definitely do not for your own
sake forget Sam try to forget ray you
have a chance for freedom and a fine
future they say everybody has to pay for
this end funny I always thought you with
a man who collected you've paid your
debt dear girl now life owes you some
happiness
let me out before you pass the plate
[Music]
[Music]
Illume 911
[Music]
hello mr. G this is your friend yes on
that business proposition we were
discussing I have another bidder who's
willing to top your offer
I don't believe we better talk on the
phone I'll jump over and see you later
wanted to be sure Yoli I'll be here
[Music]
follow that car pulling up
[Music]
the boys story makes sense to me we'll
pick up the killer of Belden and girl
[Music]
is $20 wait for me I won't be long
you don't think you're gonna park you
know yeah my fear will be right out
there ain't an open spot in the block
you may need that for a fire what do you
think y'all miss Street
don't look so grim mr. G you're in a
very enviable position yeah I'm in a
great spot let's answer it to them all
bargaining edna's finances are radically
depleted when as you have twenty five
thousand I had five grand hidden in here
that you didn't find it went to my son
Stella
amazing you could be suggestive Duncan's
with melons all night you'll kill only
the trail up elevated and down
I've got your husband for you your
name's did you kill me no I'm gonna give
you just what he got you know good
[Music]
dad I didn't know I brought the police
it's better this way
I'd rather pay the law than him
blackmail maybe the lightest rap he'll
take me I'll get the full chain
[Music]
I you still Iran didn't you bear come on
yes
yeah she came out
[Music]
you